they're coming and yet they only come to
that cultural revival and a progress
into the end of the 16th century so we
can see it took three generations for
that part of that world to absorb this
and then produce the cultural cultural
activity the late 16th century and the
other to talk about the medical on this
argument of the crisis at the end of
princely rules of society led by the
prince is no longer ruling places i
think the prices of Athenian Society
came to 1471 with the abolition of
nuclear principality and they were
unable to reassemble themselves in that
back guys into the later the end of the
16th century although we now assume that
the level of conversions and departing
this ruthenian religious helpful commute
was not as widespread as we once thought
but still was important and false I
think the difficulty over a breast I
think as far as the three-nation idea of
the Commonwealth of course is relatively
wide spread by the very beginning of 17
sector we have it already and 60
develops is frequently and they believe
that they constantly said here are three
with laney and Polar's raveena nations
in the convoy and then the move to a
political was extremely hard without a
definite leader do much agree the pawza
revolts play a role and undermining them
the divided loyalties with church
problems the Casilla was always building
things on quick set and if you were if
you were he was the major routine in
ukrainian politician who might have
expected he would have come up with some
such proposal but but what was he always
doing trying to take a situation that
was breaking down and putting it
together you've got too many fronts to
work on at that point in it I mean I
don't think this explains why something
does or doesn't
part of part of that explanation of how
difficult it was the other I guess and I
never was promiscuous big moron that is
the degree to which the common was
already close to it at that point it was
not really
for them yes nigga I think dr. once he
goes through say was he goes zoom harder
I think that it is very important to
remember that it's not the drama between
from school the other parts of the
common laws and i like to say college
because we had other parts of common
laws which is also very strong and we
are for example to open forgetting
passions the drug has a very strong
sense of identity parade smoke sensor of
the place in common well so often
special right there like influenza and
nita no one comes with that very clear
vision on it and the and the reason I I
would also say they're so my wife was
not provides a routine Ian our growth
ruthenian Alito's a period of that went
here I don't mean our soccer CFC
nobility because they
service and my guys accepted our
facilities entry they also have polish
cloud or whatever mixture between zippo
Liza I'm sock received of the territory
of Ukraine in a sense of what exit
before constantly execution of law it's
economical side was not currently of the
eastern territories united in return to
a normal new claim help c nobility never
had cysts amount of cover like nobility
of krakow a longish cause lanka because
only saw something positive and of
course krupa russia was in himself from
normal scale much stronger house which
created what's more a beautiful field of
self our common even decided about this
since nobility of routine ever had some
personal position rings at the
aristocracy aristocracy dominated and
was like every other chakra see is their
self
okay with this depend for one question
and there is I just got here first
OMG under you said correctly the 19th
century in the very sensitive water
civil society with Ted and that seems to
be citizens and subjects talking about
absolute ignorance somehow I think of
the courts Democratic Society of many
revolutions of the police positive mr.
parliamentary likely
of the Association of life are thriving
everywhere in easton girl to me that or
together sauce mexican society so you
would care for experienced a little bit
more yes true we'll split it when you
sing to me your life so what existed
existed dissidents existed a position
and very original position yes I I would
not say no they were able to to go and
fight and die and some of them digs up
and they also sought as and try to sing
like like civic life like citizens but
they were not citizens the citizenship
was taken away from them already even on
between of 19th century in the place it
was most free as I was Congress kingdom
which was created by example the first
element exists even see parliament in
Pisa our materials could not break you
loss they couldn't ask anchor or why
he's doing scissors as he couldn't
protect I remember the bishop sorry
Perryman geisha from Delhi shall
personally until
say lil say basically 67 and it is also
rising empty changes which we can float
that was the most restrictive and most
unpleasant drop all from all the
partitions yeah you need that such sense
of citizenship also died I mean people
deep by now that you but this is not
civil society civil society angry
because civil society doesn't mean silly
doesn't mean that they're citizens are
learning yes is that Muslim Ganesha can
be absolutely right after 67 that's true
but not another part of Joanna what I am
saying that I think that it is important
to understand that many many reason why
our historiography United century was
presenting Commonwealth and relation of
nation in cyber common law the way there
is because you did citizens died out a
civic way of looking at since I out and
they're fools in that period of time
stop indeed feeling that if they only
have
as austria's or its Russians or
expressions to work everybody else it
would be very powerful and wonderful and
therefore this is writing about this
story became completely difference in
writings of history before 1795 now wait
is that this Civic Society or is up
normal staff a even citizen society
which by the end of 19th century gasps
its Molly to beauty to view the moment
for Todd and he the post and ukrainians
lb the Russians airbrushes give up easy
today named looking to the Past for
every king of Poland because he was
governor and that government wanted to
bring more it take away the freedoms
which they want in 16th century taking
every ruler without the enemy and then
by the 19th century say it gathered most
and million rubles to build a monument
universal forces are phonies death of
citizen yes rebuilding is to wait civil
society but we are using the terms of
existence of civil society let's say our
Latin American countries where we know
is that civic society ? but there were
few days I am the need to say this
cuse civic society will and work history
but i would say that's a big big injury
in the Commonwealth and we'll see if
everybody can everybody lived by it
which doesn't surprise me thank you very
much for those speakers discussants we
have to move forward so the solution is
that we know in relations are long and
painful sometimes the water breaks the
session will run together yes